mesdames messieurs bonjour je voudrais
d'abord vous dire ma grande satisfaction
d'être ce matin à vos côtés à dijon avec
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur vous
l'aurez constaté vous même il s'agit
d'un 2b tout premiers déplacements en
tout cas le premier en province depuis
ma prise de fonctions en fin de semaine
dernière il ya peu juste huit jours
j'ai tenu à le faire ici parce que
simple citoyen que j'étais avait pris
comme des millions de nos concitoyens
connaissance des événements qui se sont
déroulés ici et qui avait choqué qui
m'ont choqué devenu premier ministre et
n'ayant pas l'habitude de porter des
appréciations à l'emporte-pièce c'est
bien le moins
je me suis dit il faut aller voir
total est sur place il faut aller à la
rencontre des acteurs
je sais désormais ce qui s'est passé
même si les instructions judiciaires
comme c'est le rôle finiront d'établir
la matérialité des faits et je demeure
évidemment scandalisé comme je n'étais
au début par des comportements
inadmissibles et l'indicible qui ont pu
être
perpétré c'est donc bien volontairement
avec le ministre de l'intérieur dès que
celui ci a été désignée que j'ai voulu
venir ici à dijon dire aux forces
sécurité tout le soutien du gouvernement
dans la lutte déterminée tels doivent
conduire
face à ce type d'événements
hélas à dijon où ailleurs trop fréquents